joining us right now from Sports
Illustrated let's talk some more let's
talk some some ball right now our buddy
Albert brear returns to the Rich Eisen
show how are ya Bert I'm great I would
just we just spent the first 20 minutes
talking about that great match - with
Tiger and and Peyton beating Phil and
Tom that was great I just loved every
second yeah yes I was juggling some
stuff while I was trying to watch it
like I was juggling my column and
everything and I i thought the coolest
part and like again i'm the context i
was turned out a little bit on it
but I hope the coolest part was like so
basically giving Brady a golf lesson
I think I was like when I was watching
on my holy crap would that be cool to be
out there you've got to go make open
telling you telling you what to do with
the shot you know so yeah it was quite
cool I'll mistook that was the thing
that stuck out to me is like like wow
like you know like for Brady this has
got to be pretty cool and that's a guy
who's got six super for it I know at
least he got something out of it because
he was getting some an earful I mean
from Barclays Live and then on Twitter
just an absolute total deluge people
having fun at Tom's expense you know
yeah definitely he looks like me on the
front nine and it may be a little bit
more like a pro athlete pretty much and
you got he turn around well okay so
about a half hour before we went on the
air the governors of the state of New
York Andrew Cuomo and New Jersey Phil
Murphy announced that teams can return
to facilities and both the Giants and
Jets sent out statements saying that
we're looking into it we'll do it when
when it's when it's best for our
operations but it certainly looks like
dovetailing the comments from Stephen
Ross the owner of the Dolphins who does
have many businesses from malls to gyms
and all that sort of stuff that so him
being optimistic in public helps a lot
of his businesses but it does certainly
look right now Albert like this is a go
would you say that that's the general
sentiment right now with the NFL yeah
you know I so I mean there's still like
a lot of restrictions at least a
they do reopen where you know NFL teams
wouldn't be able to bring everybody back
and I think if you look at the timeline
of reopening in places like New Jersey
in New York in Washington State
Massachusetts in California certainly I
don't think there's a real likelihood
that they'll be able to get everyone
back in the building in those sorts of
places by the time you know what we're
spraying on the NFL calendar and which
is going to be I believe June 26 so wait
I think you'll see over the next month
is really teams starting to filter
people back in so they can test some of
the protocols they put in place the good
news is is that this does put them in
position to open training camp on time
which would put us on schedule to open
the season on time so I'd be surprised
it's you know you get players and masks
back in buildings you know at any point
over the next month you know but you
know what you might see is you might see
where like you know K League wants to
see what it looks like what players in
some places and so they may say well you
can't go out and have a practice because
that would give you an advantage of
these other teams but if you want to go
in and meet maybe you can do that and
that would be the first sign of the NFL
really like seriously breaking you know
what had been I think pretty protective
measures from a competitive balance
standpoint to kind of insulate the teams
that are in the areas of more
restrictive rules so I guess what are
you hearing about everything else that
Troy Vincent the head of football
operations saying that essentially that
they're gonna go full-bore expect a full
season on time with fans until they're
told otherwise and the owner of the
Dolphins Steven Ross saying there is a
plan to have at least 15,000 fans at
Dolphins games you know this fall what
is the timeline from what you're hiring
for elite with it with a league that's
that's essentially taken full advantage
of them not having to have one over the
last several months in a way that other
sports who were interrupted a hat
I think it's I think it's okay to say I
think it's okay for everybody to say I
don't know because we don't know what
this going to look like July or August
you know that said yeah there's
definitely been progress you know and I
do think you know there eventually have
to cross that bridge where you know
there are going to be some inequities
where you know one state's going to
allow this another States not going to
allow that
it's me problematic for one team and
maybe not so much for another you know
at this point they've had that luxury
like you said where they don't have to
do anything they're at a point in a
calendar where it's okay for them just
sit back and kind of watch what happens
with everybody else and they're gonna
have that luxury over a couple months to
which I mean as baseball and basketball
and hockey get back to work they're
gonna get a chance to look at what those
force do right what those sports do
wrong and incorporate to what they're
doing
I would like as far as like what toy is
saying like sort of instance saying the
league office has to take care of the
teams and right now the teams are going
to have to sell tickets and so they do
have to project project confidence to
their customers but they're going to at
least try to do this so they can move
the product you know but I think there
are certain places you know certainly
the teams out there in LA that I think
are very much planning for the reality
that they could start the season without
fans in the center with a limited number
of fans in the Stanford so so much this
as you know is going to be based on what
happens state to state but I'd expect
them to kind of be confident about the
ideas they could have fans in the stands
come come September October with
knowledge that it's probably going to be
different from one team to the next
Oliver Brer the mm QB senior NFL
reporter Sports Illustrated here on the
Rich Eisen show what's going down this
week with the ownership they're voting
remotely on some rules changes what
what's set the week up here as we head
into June 2020 our you know like now the
oxide kick like alternative got a lot of
attention we'll get to that but I don't
know one of my apps most impact like I
don't know why this was afraid are as
much did last week but I mean the sky
judge being voted on I think is huge and
the fact of the competition committee is
now behind the sky adjusting is it
honest to you know in the passenger
fares thing went in last year rich that
was seen by the thirty two head coaches
as a step towards getting a sky judge
they all want us guys I'm telling you
like that number of coaches that are in
favor of the sky judge is like 90 to 95
percent and like that the few holdouts
only are that way because they want to
see how the mechanics of it work and
like all those coaches like what a
mechanism where the officials have the
benefit that we all have at home like
where you've got infinite different
angles and crystal-clear HD like why do
all of us have that at home and the
officials in the field don't get the
benefit of that the coaches want the
officiating crews to have that benefit
and so the idea of putting in the pass
interference review thing last year was
seen by those 32 coaches as a step
towards the sky judge they're gonna vote
on the sky judge this week unless they
decide and I think that this is probably
the most likely scenario to go with it
and as an experimental thing in
pre-season and then make a decision at
the end of August they want to employ
parts of it into the season and then
maybe vote on the whole thing in 2021
but it sure sounds like the sky judge is
coming and they're gonna discuss that
this week and then of course there's
sort of that fun rule change that we can
you know all the date till we're blue in
the face we're you know teams are going
to have the chance to vote on a proposal
from the Eagles which is going to give
you two times every game the chance
instead of an onside kick to get a
fourth and 15 snap the 25-yard line
there's been unintended consequences
there but that's something that's you
know it's route a health and safety
measure because the onside kick such a
dangerous play but you know obviously is
going to be something that would have a
big effect on other ways the end of some
gangsta play out let's uh let's take
this one at a time here Albert how does
the sky judge work from what you've been
told and understand because you know
that the minute that you have
buddy upstairs after a play is done not
throwing a flag while it's being done
but using replay to run through to
relitigate a play in the mere seconds
that we've got between that play and the
next play only serves to lend a serious
level of frustration to the viewer at
home if not in the stadium to know when
a flag has been thrown and for what and
why how what is the actual mechanics of
this well you hit on the key point which
is the play clock and the play clocks
couldn't govern a lot of this and you
know there's certain place where when we
see them on TV like it's obvious to us
right like like oh my god they got that
one wrong that's clearly wrong and there
are other ones were when you look at it
from 10 different angles yeah I got that
wrong you know and so there's a
difference between the two and I think
the play clock is going to govern this
and that the guy up top has very little
time to get to the head referee and say
you got this wrong so it's got to be
obvious you know just logically if you
look at the time constraint there and so
there's gonna be two instances where the
booth official or the booth on fire this
guy judge is going to come into play and
he's going to report the head refer
referee so he's going to be part of the
officiating crew one is he can bunt down
to him within the first 15 minutes of
the play clock so once it's the play
clocks at 25 seconds he can't buzz down
anymore the other is if the if the head
referee wants to use him as a resource
and he can buzz up to him and so like I
think that way that that that that sort
of kind of alleviates some of the issues
that you might have with the with
delaying the game or slowing the game
down because it all happy an obvious
mess for for this whole thing to get
triggered which i think is what we're
all looking for for those things to get
corrected and you got to give the
coaches credit for this because the
coaches are the ones who worked up
they're a bunch of guys Bill O'Brien
John Harbaugh Ron Rivera Mike Tomlin
Sean pate they're a bunch of guys that
work really hard to get this right and
that want to see you know the technology
that we all have that artists
so incorporate into the way the games
officiated and so I think there's an
efficient way to do it and through hard
work I think that they feel like they
found that that's that area you can do
this an efficient way we're all slow
down the game and think about this to
probably take some unnecessary
challenges out of the game which is a
plus for everybody as well well that's
that's one thing I guess but to me what
you just said Albert sounds exactly what
was said in support of making pass
interference reviewable everything that
you just said hey only the obvious hey
we got to get the obvious right hey
people are seeing it at home you know we
got to use it to fix it and that's what
the coaches want they want it reasonable
and then and then when it came time to
actually putting it into play then the
powers that be
and they're you know you could say it's
either the you know the Operations
Office or or the officiating Department
which is you know obviously under NFL
operations you know that that somebody
just didn't I'll say somebody have the
stomach for it where they didn't they in
that and that that's what's been point I
mean that's what Sean Payton said on our
buddy Locke and Forrest show in
Baltimore a couple weeks ago and or
absolutely intimated that sentiment and
it made news because here's the the
coach who tried to make it happen and
was the most aggrieved party saying that
hey it could have worked if the NFL had
gotten a right or wanted to do it or had
the gumption for doing it why aren't we
gonna have the same thing
replay out with Scott Judge well you
know it's funny because I think it's
sort of like I'll take you inside the
politics of this please that I think you
know I think that this is third there
are politics involved and I don't know
how much you guys followed what happened
at the owners meetings last year but
there really was you know last year like
they after what happened at the Saints
Rams game at the end at the agencies and
the owners meetings in Arizona the 32
coaches banded together and said we need
to get this fixed and you know I think
that where they saw the pass
interference capacitor fairness
challenge system it's
of a middle ground and a step towards
the sky judge I really think the
officiating Department took that is like
this isn't right for us this is gonna
make our job that much harder and we
weren't really you know this didn't
really work for us so you know like
between our River on the on field
officials the coaches there was no well
there and I think that there were there
was a lot of feeling that there was push
and pull on that in the way that it was
officiated during the season in 2019 and
I think the way the coaches have
addressed this is now they're taking
themselves out of it and they said we're
giving you an extra official now and
that guy is going to be part of your
crew so it's not us throwing challenge
flags and making your job more difficult
somebody who's going to be part of your
crew and reporting to your head referee
there's going to be a resource to you so
we're not calling you out for mistakes
we're not Talent in the way that your
face gauging the game we're giving you a
resource and we're putting that resource
on your crew so you'll have a
relationship with a guy and you'll be
able to work with him and he will be a
backstop to give you something that you
haven't had over the years I that makes
all the sense in the world maybe I'm
wrong but this whole thing kind of
turned into a match last year we all
witnessed that in real time and it
really I do I think underneath all of it
there was this push and pull between the
officials and the coaches and now I
think the solution that the coaches have
worked on with the competition committee
and then tried to make work here is we
want to just help the officials here we
don't want to make this us versus them
we want to help the officials make the
game better and they think they've done
it with this Alber brewer here on the
Rich Eisen show okay then
I love the the rule of let's go for it
on fourth and 15 from the 25 I love it
you know some coaches are gonna we spoke
to Frank Reich about it on on Friday and
we said you know his his former boss in
Philly Doug Peterson is our guest as the
first coach to do it well up in again to
steal a second possession in the same
manner that we're seeing so many coaches
go 4-2 when there are up seven instead
of just adding on the extra point to
make it eight forcing another team to go
for it
to try and tie a game they're going for
two to go up nine it's just one play
from the two yard line someone's gonna
do the math and figure out going for it
op makes sense is that the unintended
consequence you're talking about what
unintended consequence did you refer to
earlier about that from what you're here
yeah coach actually kind of laid this
out for me over the weekend where so you
know say you see your score say he
scores a go-ahead touchdown and you're
up and there's like ten seconds left
right and you got to kickoff to the
other team could you run a 1415 play on
the last play of the game snap the ball
run around for ten seconds of the game's
over you know so there's sort of some
circumstances there where you can sort
of use that play in a way it's not
intended to be used where I mean look
it's not the end of the world if you
know what I mean but that isn't really
the way that's not really why you're
putting the rule in and so there are
some circumstances you know that was why
it was suggested at one point maybe this
should only be allowed if you're a head
perfect or if you're behind and not if
you're a head so there are certain kinks
in the world I think they would have to
they'd have to work out and they are
probably gonna get brought up on this
conference call
but look the bottom line in here is you
know rich they've identified the onside
kick is a very dangerous play right and
we know like owners because of
everything they went through with a
concussion litigation or everything else
they don't like to go back backwards on
health and safety matters and if you're
viewing this is a health and safety
matter it's gonna be voted on that way I
think it probably goes through and I
mean currently Eagles two for coming up
with a with a with a fun solution that
could kind of added a different wrinkle
to the game in the end so yeah I think
there are an intended consequences and
you know I think that the one up being
excused a head and using it as a way to
like drain the clock like that could be
an issue but I don't think it's anything
that's I don't know I mean going forward
fourth and 15 and that from what I could
read in the in the in the in the rule if
there's a holding penalty on
play you still have to go for it on 4th
and 25 you can't just say oh now we'll
kick it now we're gonna kick it you
can't do that the minute you go for it
from fourth and fifth there's a huge
risk I mean any penalty means that you
have to try it again from longer away
you know I mean that's not only that not
only that race but you'd be like so I
said yeah that holding penalty now it's
4th in 25 from the 15 yeah well you know
now the other team gets possession at
the 15 if you throw an incomplete pass
right you just write the fall there
because you're like out well we have to
like push them a little further out you
know what I mean like there's so much
sizing involved in that part it should
be really a try I know so you know if so
if somebody uh who's up wants to mess
around to try and steal a possession or
you know run some clock I mean that it's
the there's there's a lot of risk before
that reward would hit so that's why I
love it I cuz the onside kick it's just
you know certainly under the new player
safety rules which I have no problem
with it makes it even more difficult to
convert and then the number of times
that the reason why it works isn't
because the kicker made such a great
swing of the leg that the ball pops in
the air and and it's great it just means
somebody else screwed up because it's a
total scramble play and you're just
hoping that somebody else screws up and
it's you know I know it's been that 400
years but they like they like not just
onside kicks to kick off in general it
sort of been I think in peril for the
last 10 years because everything we've
learned about like the dangers of it
everything else you know IIIi think like
finding you know fun ways to make the
play so to preserve the play I think
they're good and this you know could
wind up being a way to preserve the play
long-term you know and like I said like
the XFL and you know you know God rest
their soul
but the XFL their solution to the
kickoff to the kickoff situation I
thought it was a really good one like I
looked at that and I was like wow that's
me in a sausage feel and so there's no
question I mean they've been sort of
working on trying to fix the kickoff
from the health and safety standpoint
forever and this one
a really really interesting piece of
strategy okay couple of things to hit
you on before letting you go on your
Tuesday are my colleague from ESPN my
buddy John Clayton said from back in the
day that he's here in Russell Wilson
would love to add Antonia brown in
Seattle is there any they're there for
that yeah there are a lot of hurdles
that the Seahawks that a Antonio Brown
still has to clear and I just wonder
it's a Seahawks with the situation
they're dealing with with Quinton Dunbar
now if they would be in position to roll
the dice on someone like Antonio Brown
they have shown interest in him in the
past so they've done the background work
on him and everything else in the idea
that's really fun especially because you
know the Seahawks have you know DK
Metcalf and Tyler Lockett like so you've
got it good they've got any well dizzily
coming back now a tight end off injury
they've got a decent emerging young
group around Russell Wilson and so it'd
be fun the idea of Antonio Brown is a
player being thrown in that mix and they
have done the homework on him I just
wonder if after the Dunbar situation if
they're in a position to fear that and
then you know whether or not Browns
capable in the hurdles he's going to be
declared exactly okay and then the dak
Prescott contract
you know usually as you know it's a mid
not just a midnight League it's a 12:01
League so you wait to the very end which
would be what middle of June July 15
middle of July yeah okay so be that as
it may I think we've got a long way to
go what do you say to people who think
that DAX not worth the money that he's
reportedly asking for I think the
problem is the question than what and I
know people do the equation like oh well
you know if you had Andy Dalton to you
know seven other players you'd be able
to afford if you away from that Prescott
well wouldn't you have a better team
then and my answer to that is well yeah
you might be really good and then you
guys turn around and pay Andy doll you
tell me what you want to do you know
it's just it's a question it's a
question that gets asked because the
quarterback markets was so far beyond
everything else and
I mean look these teams have this great
little window when they've got you know
young quarterbacks at a cheap rate so
the Texans have benefited from that the
Chiefs benefited from that the Eagles
and Rams for a bunch of years benefited
from that eventually the bill comes due
and you know you've heard for years and
years how like some smart team is gonna
wind up turning four to backs I think
the problem is the alternative is that
you're sort of out there with everybody
else looking for for the next guy and
that's not an easy spot to be in so you
know I think I need to get back done
before July so it seems I think the key
to the whole thing is going to be the
length of the deal not the dollars and I
didn't get be smart to get it done
before Patrick John Watson you know
because the price only goes up they
didn't get it done before they didn't
get it done before whence or golf I mean
the price only goes right as you wait
that's I mean that's the thing is like
if we're sitting here I mean like look
like yeah the 40 million sound like a
lot for a quarterback right now yeah it
does because Russell Walters you know at
35 and he's the highest-paid now and
that's five million more than thirty
five I bought if you wait like if you
decide okay like we're gonna sit here
away you know it's possible a month from
now we maybe have two guys you could
have Watson and the Holmes making 40
million a year now the sudden that's the
bar and I think they're gonna get done
that quickly but I mean we've all seen
what happens at the quarterback market
with the quarterback market it doesn't
doesn't stagnate it just constantly
incremental moves up and so yeah I think
that there be a definite price to pay if
you're waiting to do that and you know
all you guys do is ask the Washington
Redskins have a third cousin situation
played out if you want you know a
roadmap for you know what making a
quarterbacks plan the franchise tag does
for you yeah
again at some point you're right when
you see turning quarterbacks you know
dak is the perfect example of successful
shows a ton of promise
lots of upside has a ton of great stats
still coming off however one of the more
disappointing cowboy seasons ever and
everybody who blames the coach now that
the coach is gone is blaming deck and
and I I'm just saying it's his turn it's
his time you got a Pam before you get
into this problem and ride with him
that's it the kid the kid is supremely
talented and I do believe another team
as is I think this opinions becoming
less and less popular certainly within
my own studio because Brockman's
laughing over there himself you know
he's the king of you know you know Andy
Dalton stinks until actually I could use
him as my own quarterback in New England
but then he winds up in Dallas and dak
isn't worth it let's go with Andy Dalton
like literally that's been your stance
correct Chris exact I mean I just don't
think dak should be the highest-paid
player in the NFL he doesn't deserve it
I mean it's pretty simple wait a minute
all right wait for Chris good Jimmy
Garoppolo deserve it
the Kirk Cousins deserve it no have they
want anything Albert but but but Derek
Carr is a great example right like Derek
Carr signed his deal I believe it was
2000
I want the mmm right or 2016 maybe right
in there someone or no it was later than
that it was acted like he was a 14
rookie so it would have been 2017 that's
three years ago okay three years ago
Derek Carr was the highest-paid
quarterback in football when he signed
his deal okay do you know how people are
talking about his contract now Chris
Wright a bargain that's why they keep
him around I get it but you know what
his record is in the last three years
he's won 17 games in three years all
right Andrew Luck was making 25 million
you would be if Andrew Luck were still
playing at 25 million dollars a year
he's done that deal three years ago like
yes why I'm sorry you gotta do it early
you got to do it early and then you you
know unlike cuz of Kirk Cousins is the
rarity where you get paid like you're
you're you're an outfielder you're
getting paid like you're a starting
pitcher you know which is guaranteed
money you guineas he's getting paid like
Gerrit Cole yeah you know he's it's
amazing yeah it's the price of doing
business of that position I mean it's
like what like you get if you get it
right like it's a good problem to have
and I think you have to sort of approach
it that way you know like it's like yeah
it sucks that you know maybe there are
three or four guys who would be on your
team otherwise that aren't there anymore
because you because because you paid
your quarterback but like having
stability that position is the most
important thing and it's priced as such
you know what I mean like there's that
price tag is on there because what
everyone's looking for is to be as
stable as you possibly can be at the
most important position
Albert you the man everybody everything
good house how's your wife doing I know
again I know she's in health care and as
have things improved or what yeah you
know the health care system up here you
know like they were taxed for a while
and Bob you know they absolutely set up
a couple field field and field hospitals
in the Boston area as a result of that
but things have settled down and you
know the really cool thing is you know
you've seen a lot of people public like
a lot of the like there's been uh an
outpouring of support for people in
those places in fact today you know wall
burgers which is I don't you guys
happened out there
no but mark oh yes you know it sure sure
so so family got an email this morning
that like her unit like Wahlburgers sent
flash over for everyone in the unit
today and so like you see little things
like that like where you know people are
reaching out and and and thanking the
teeth the doctors and the nurses you
know over out there doing God's work you
know in really fun ways and so it's been
cool to see that I know she's really
felt that it's I know how much it's
appreciated
- from all those people that that they
feel like their work is being people are
paying attention to the good work
they're doing
Albert you the man that's your family
best to everybody and I appreciate you
spending a half an hour on the phone
with me catching us up on the NFL
appreciate it while we're on the phone I
don't know who your colleague at Yahoo
but reporting that many camps could be
scheduled as early as June 15th and his
latest June 27th like we can actually
see practice yeah well yeah that would
be yes so that the calendar goes the
26th so if they were gonna have mini
camps if they were gonna have some form
of players coming in right then getting
work done again I think will be part of
the part of like testing their protocols
but yeah I mean it would have to happen
some point in the last two weeks at you
negotiated with the union okay Albert
thanks for the call appreciate it
well chat soon okay thank you have a
prayer hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here